ok today we're going to look at measures
of obesity we're going to have a look at
BMI we're going to look at waist-hip
ratio and see what they could tell us
about obesity so obesity is being
overweight and having a large larger
than normal proportion of body fat the
reason why we might want to know if
someone is obese because obesity is
linked to health problems such as
diabetes type 2 so first of all gonna
have a look at BMI so BMI stands for
body mass index now as you can see
there's an equation that we need to know
here
BMI equals mass over person's height
squared so the important thing about BMI
is it considers both mass and height
because if you just measured someone's
mass it might give us a false result
someone really tall could kind of come
through is looking like they're obese
because they're so tall they might have
a high mass so it needs to factor in
mass and height like this so we've got
two individuals just here person 1 and
person 2 so the first thing we need to
do let's measure their height so we use
a tape measure to measure this person's
height and let's say for sake of
argument this person's height is 1.7
meters we also need to get their to sit
on a set of scales to measure their mass
let's say this person's mass is 70
kilograms so let's now go over here and
find out for person 1 what their BMI is
so the BMI equals their mass which in
this case is 70 kilograms divided by the
height squared now this bit is really
important people when they're doing this
equation off the miss the squared it's
really really important otherwise we're
going to get a very very different value
for your BMI so let's just simplify the
bottom I'm just gonna get my calculator
now you'd be using a scientific
calculator but this shows up better on
their video so one point seven times one
point seven says 137 squared is two
point eight nine so seventy divided
by two point eight nine so this person's
BMI just work it out seventy divided by
D equal eight nine this person I'm going
to do for three significant figures
which is twenty four point two twenty
four points here now what does that
number mean first of all BMI doesn't
have any units it's just the number in
itself it only makes sense if you look
at something like this so you don't need
to learn these you'll be given this if
you have if you need to in an exam all
you need to do is see which category
twenty four point two falls within and
then you can see the description so this
person falls within their BMI falls
within here so they have a normal weight
they are not overweight or underweight
so let's do the same thing for the
second person so the second person again
you need to measure their height let's
say this person's height is looks like
that slightly shorter so let's say 1.6
meters and this person's carrying a bit
more weight let's say this person is a
hundred kilograms so over here for
number two let's work out this person's
BMI now so again the same idea height
which sorry mass which is a hundred over
height squared one point six squared so
I'm just going to simplify that first of
all I do in the bottom first
so I solve it one twenty six squared so
one point six times one point six so
it's a hundred over two point five six
unless you see what that is real quick
one hundred right away two point five
six equals when I'll do it to three
significant figures so that would round
to thirty nine point one again let's see
the second person now this time this
person falls into this category thirty
to forty so they'd be moderately obese
getting towards being severely obese so
their doctor might advise them to lose
some weight
otherwise they run the risk for perhaps
developing diabetes type two so there's
one measure of obesity
another measure of obesity is looking at
waist-hip ratio now it's kind of
preferable to have a smaller waist
compared to your hips if we've got a
much bigger waist again we're carrying a
quite a bit more body fat and therefore
we might be at risk to certain certain
problems so um let's have a look how
this works for a to individual so let's
say we've got same individuals before so
let's first of all take this person's
waist measurement now to find the weight
waist measurement you need to do all the
way around a tape measure all the way
around the body the whole circumference
around the body from the belly button so
first person let's say that value for
their waist is 75 centimeters for the
hips
you need to line it up with the hip bone
and do it all around the body so second
one let's say that value is 80
centimeters so to find the waist hip
ratio so this is person 1 right here all
you need to do it's really nice and easy
you do the waist measurement divided by
the hip measurement so waist is 75
divided by the hip measurement which is
80 so let's have a quick look let's just
get my calculator
okay so 75 divided by 80 equals whether
it's three significant figures which
would be zero point nine three eight so
zero point nine three eight would be
their waist hip ratio so point nine
three eight now number two let's have a
look now they've got a bigger waist so
again it's round belly button all the
way around the whole body the
circumference around the body and their
hips are here so let's say this time the
top measurement was a hundred and twelve
centimeters and the bottom measurement
was a hundred centimeters so again for
number two you do the exact same thing
now it's actually quite nice to remember
which one's divided my waist one because
the waist your waist is above your hips
so your waist is over your hips and it's
waist over hips the waist divided by
hips so this one would be
12/100 which equals let's just have a
look 100
well divided by a hundred oops
divided by 100 which equals one point
one two so equals one point one two now
wasting ratio again you will be given
this but you're carrying too much too
much weight if your waist hip ratio is
above one point zero for males and above
0.85 for females and that's because
females often have wider hips so that's
how to use wasting ratio and body mass
index thank you